6 45 on your wednesday morning what's
driving me crazy here's the straight up
skinny
on flipping a huey viewer adriana writes
about a specific intersection but her
email applies
anywhere u-turns are legal in nevada she
writes every time i make a u-turn from
west
to go east on blue diamond and rainbow
some drivers who are turning right
onto northbound from northbound rainbow
on to eastbound blue diamond they keep
going
even though she's got the green light
she writes sometimes the u-turning
drivers have to slam on their brakes in
the middle of turning she says i've
almost rear-ended somebody what is the
law
are people just being jerks well adriana
can't answer the part about jerky
drivers but here's someone who
definitely knows the law
morning nate trooper travis smacka here
and i appreciate the question that your
viewer had
about the intersection at blue diamond
and rainbow so today i'm going to drive
through that intersection
and we'll kind of go over what the
question was about the vehicle that's
going westbound and has a green signal
to make a u-turn
is the vehicle that has the right-of-way
any vehicle that's making a right turn
against a red signal must come to a full
and complete
stop and yield to oncoming traffic i
hope that clarifies things a little bit
and i'd just like to remind everyone to
have a great morning and to drive safely
thank you thank you trooper smackah and
thanks to adriana for writing in
buckle up drive carefully and of course
please put down that phone
if there is something driving to crazy
email me traffic eight eightnewsnow.com